so um I've talked before about the
problem of chiropractors and now we are
actually seeing chiropractors who many
of whom are are anti-vaccine and I'll
talk about what I mean when I say many
uh chiropractors are increasingly a
force of misinformation as reported by
the Associated Press uh let's read a
little bit of this article and then I'm
going to give you some some of my
thoughts
um this is an article from Providence
Rhode Island about a um event called vax
con 21 promoted as teaching people the
uncensored truth about covid vaccines
and people went uh participants traveled
from around the country to a Wisconsin
Dells Resort for a sold-out convention
that was a sea of misinformation and
conspiracy theories the featured speaker
was the anti-vaxx activist from the 2020
movie pandemic the convention was
organized by members of a profession
that has been become a major purveyor of
vaccine misinformation during the
pandemic chiropractors
at a time when the Surgeon General says
misinformation has become an urgent
threat to Public Health
an investigation by the AP found a vocal
and influential group of chiropractors
capitalizing on the pandemic by sowing
fear and mistrust of vaccines they've
touted supplements as alternatives to
vaccines written doctors notes to allow
patients to get out of mask and
immunization mandates donated large sums
of money to anti-vaccine organizations
and sold anti-vaccine ads on Facebook
and Instagram the AP discovered
one chiropractor gave thousands to a
Super PAC hosting anti-vaccine pro-trump
rally on January 6th they have also been
the leading force behind anti-vaxx
events like the one in Wisconsin where
hundreds of chiropractors from around
the country shelled out 299 dollars to
attend the AP found chiropractors were
allowed to earn continuing ed credits to
maintain their licenses in at least 10
states going on to say Public Health
Advocates are alarmed by the number of
chiropractors hitching themselves to the
anti-vaccine movement using their public
prominence and Sheen of medical
expertise to undermine the nation's
response to a pandemic that has killed
seven hundred thousand so let's talk
about chiropractors okay
I'm not 100 against chiropractors I'm
about 85 against them and here's what
what I'll Tell You by that
um when you in some places people go to
a chiropractor almost like a primary
care doctor in fact in California uh
chiropractors can be pcps
and they are often anti-vaccine and they
often promote a ton of different woo so
the stuff from chiropractors that's a
disaster includes uh things like for the
anti-vaccine stuff as well as
Chiropractic adjustments as treatments
for systemic conditions of different
kinds infections
Etc uh neck adjustments back adjustments
Etc just simply no evidence that they
treat infections and other systemic
conditions okay number two
a lot of chiropractors are in the woo
stuff like and you can see some of these
on YouTube I mean there's people that go
to chiropractors on YouTube they film it
and you hear stuff like make sure to
drink a lot of extra water after the
adjust adjustment to flush out the
toxins released by the back cracking and
the neck stuff that I did that's total
nonsense I mean just when you think
about how the Body Works drink water to
flush through the kidneys for a
adjustment it just doesn't make sense
okay so that you got to be very very
careful with next stuff check out on
YouTube and uh articles from spine
surgeons and back surgeons about the
risk of neck adjustments and what can
happen from neck manipulations done by
chiropractors so all of this stuff is
horrible huge you know at best you're
spending money on something that will do
nothing
um and at worst you you could end up
really hurt now what's the part that
maybe is okay
there are some things chiropractors do
that are also done by physical
therapists and are more within the realm
of reality as long as you understand
their goal so like for example I once
went to a physical therapist when I was
having some back pain and they do some
very specific back cracking things not
where you put a strap under your neck
and pull to extend no but just some
specific back cracking things which they
say this is not really treatment but
while we're building a routine for you
to strengthen muscles and maybe deal
with a spasm or whatever
some of these specific back crackings
can provide some short-term relief okay
beyond that we've got to be really
careful with chiropractors so it's not a
surprise that this is a group
that is doing things that are horrible
including as we covered in Florida
saying just come on down and I'll sign
off on a mask or vaccine exemption for
you
um and that is uh extraordinarily
concerning and I'm really glad that the
AP is writing about this
um it says the purveyors of vaccine
misinformation represent the small but
vocal minority of the nation's 70 000
chiropractors many of whom advocate for
vaccines so I think that that's
important and what what I've said to
people when they say so should no one go
to a chiropractor I you could this is
not my idea you can find this
information online what should be done
if you're considering going to a
chiropractor is you call up and you
actually ask their view on Chiropractic
adjustments and you say Do you believe
Chiropractic adjustments can be used to
for example treat things like sinus
infections or I mean it might you know
cancer imagine what's your view on
vaccination
Etc you can usually pretty quickly if
you ask there's like five or six
questions you can find online to ask a
possible chiropractor
you can pretty quickly suss out like
which which side of things they're on
you can also more than likely get what
you need from a physical therapist and
there you're talking about uh different
different type of setting and uh that
may be something to consider as well but
chiropractors increasingly a source of
anti-vaccine disinformation let's move
on to another source of disinformation